so we laid out we had the first january
6 commission months ago
proposed and rejected by republicans we
then got close to another one
but then when nancy pelosi said jim
jordan and jim banks they can't be on
the commission they're part of the
problem republicans went nuts
now they're saying they're going to do
their own commission and
it's an absolute and complete joke the
reaction from republicans
and the right-wing media to this has
been to start pushing
new conspiracy theories about what
happened
on january 6th uh laura ingraham
running on fox news a
headline called nancy the
insurrectionist
pelosi exploits january 6th in a
ruthless power grab
because she said two of the five
republican choices can't be on the
commission
remember that republicans could have
gone forward
with the commission as proposed months
ago and nancy pelosi wouldn't even have
had the power
to reject any of the choices of the
republicans
then the right-wing media continuing
tucker carlson actually inviting jim
jordan
onto his program last night jim jordan
is one of the members of congress that
nancy pelosi said no
this guy's an insider he can't be on the
commission
um and pushed the conspiracy theory
still baseless
that the riots were a setup by the fbi
christopher wray refused to get on a
conference call about
preparation for january 6 before it
happened
they knew it was coming they didn't
protect the building they let the
protesters in
the fbi has a long history of setting up
crimes they just now remember
every single one of these things has to
be looked at in detail there was
the videos of law enforcement moving
aside
it's a typical crowd control thing where
when the crowd is overwhelming the crowd
control measures and the crowd
controllers and law enforcement to a
certain degree
it's typical that those doing the crowd
control
will move aside and sort of like allow
the perimeter
to be shifted because it starts to
present a danger
to them as well as to the people to the
public that
it's it's not it's not the big smoking
gun that these republicans want to make
it out to be the big smoking gun is
trump
refusing to actually allow the national
guard in for hours despite being asked
did it in michigan we're going to get
into it in a second why isn't there a
good
faith investigation into the fbi's
behavior or do republicans somehow trust
the fbi
well tucker you may remember a few weeks
ago when we had the fbi
director in front of the judiciary
committee i asked him about what
happened to the hoopers
up in the in the state of alaska who
were their door was kicked in they were
handcuffed that held at gunpoint and
interrogated for four hours
they weren't even in the capitol okay so
that's the that's the idea that the fbi
this is the reaction okay to the
commission the fbi set it up
then laura ingram does a segment with
kevin mccarthy
where mccarthy starts floating this idea
that it was nancy pelosi
that was responsible for the national
guard not being there
when the riots were going on and the
national guard were there and nancy
pelosi was criticizing
because they were they were at the
lincoln memorial protecting it
was there a decision made by the speaker
not to have the national guard
at the capitol that day when they found
the that's the new one
it's it's not trump that was pence
mccarthy everybody's saying send in the
troops and trump saying
no as he watches us from the white house
now they're saying it's all pelosi's
fault that's what it is
and uh jim banks another one of the
insiders floating the exact same idea
jordan and i would ask the tough
questions that they didn't want to
answer about the the systemic breakdown
of security at the capitol on january 6
and ultimately who's responsible for
that the speaker of the house
they don't want to go there they knew we
were going to ask the tough question
so that's the concerted effort you can
just see they've decided this is going
to be what we're going to talk about
let's say it's
it was nancy pelosi responsible for what
happened and then lastly
uh here is tucker carlson attacking
harry dunn the black police officer
who was attacked by rioters on january
6. it's beyond the pale information
what's the answer of course she doesn't
have one speaking of disingenuous
so the committee will proceed with one
party what will look like we'll think
msnbc with subpoena power on tuesday
pelosi will call a capital police
officer called harry dunn
dunn will pretend to speak for the
country's law enforcement community
but it turns out dunn has very little in
common with your average cop
dunn is an angry left-wing political
activist whose social media feeds are
full of praise
not coincidentally for nancy pelosi
here's a picture of the two of them
together racism is so american
harry dunn wrote a one post that when
you protest it people think you're
protesting america
leave it to whites to tell blacks what
is racist hashtag
i stand with elon omar hashtag squad
harry done ladies and gentlemen just
another fact so to support the police
people
now attacking the police victimized by
the trump rioters on january 6th
these people cannot be trusted to
investigate obviously
but they can't even be relied upon to
provide
even the most fundamental unquestionable
fact
so we'll see what this starts to look
like next week we'll save much more
probably on monday
remember that monday august 16th is the
16th anniversary of the david pakman
show we'll be doing a one-day membership
special
i'd love for you to participate get
notified
on the 16th simply by getting on my
newsletter at davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors today is blue blocks
blue blocks glasses
filter out the blue light coming from
your computer screen your phone your tv
which can be really helpful because blue
light from screens
can cause eye strain headaches even
trouble
sleeping at night these are my blue
blocks glasses they've been
a big help i'm no longer feeling that
eye strain i'm falling asleep easier at
night
because blue light suppresses the sleep
hormone
melatonin so the blue blox glasses just
make it easier to fall asleep at night
for many people
and blue blocks is the company you can
trust because their glasses were
developed in actual
optics labs in line with the
peer-reviewed academic literature
they have 40 different frames to choose
from there's even a prescription version
they also have readers there's really
something for everybody
go to blue blocks dot com slash pacman
and you'll get
twenty percent off everything in their
store plus free shipping worldwide
on orders over a hundred and fifteen
dollars